[Applauso]
il naga e la grande festa del popolo
mongolo una sorta di olimpiade la più
antica dopo quella della grecia è
partecipano quasi tutti gli uomini di
ulan bataar e della steppa
si inizia la bambini con la corsa a
cavallo poi si passa al torneo di lotta
quindi anziani al torneo di tiro con
l'arco in sintesi le tre età dell'uomo
la giovinezza fatta di coraggio e di
voglia di fare la forza la
determinazione dell'età adulta
la precisione la cura di quella della
vecchiaia
io certo non sono un erede di gengis
khan ma credo di aver vissuto più o meno
la stessa esperienza da ragazzo sono
stato uno scalatore e un alpinista di un
certo livello fino ai 30 anni
dopodiché ho iniziato ad occuparmi di
cinematografia
ovviamente legata alla montagna ai posti
estremi eccetera
e infine doppiata la boa dei 60 anni e
ho cominciato a dedicarmi alla scrittura
non è che sia cambiato molto io mi sento
nello stesso ragazzotto lo stesso
marello di un tempo
la stessa voglia di andare di
confrontarmi di sperimentare di
raccontare prendersi cura
a mio avviso significa soprattutto
coltivare se stessi attraverso la
propria vocazione e non è che sia una
vocazione soltanto di carattere
religioso come quella dei giovani monaci
tibetani e dei loro interminabili
cammini in prostrazione si parla di
vocazione anche in campo scientifico
culturale artistico una splendida
malattia che il cui contagio può
avvenire molto presto sintesi hegeliana
delle due categorie
gli amatori e i professionisti in
maniaci che sono estremamente più
interessanti sono tipo dei sisifo felici
e sospingono la loro passione tutti i
giorni cima alla montagna felici nel
vederla rotolare a valle per poterla
respingere di nuovo in su seguono dei
progetti per anni anche se ormai hanno
capito che non lo realizzeranno più
questo progetto perché non è senza
scomodare siddharta non è così
importante
la meta quanto il viaggio meglio ancora
la lunga infinita rincorsa che precede
il salto e non importa quanto lungo
atterrerà nella sabbia perché è il
momento in cui ti libri dal suolo e che
aleggi nell'aria
la cosa più importante bisogna essere
mani a perseguire un'idea che ti è
venuto in mente da bambino per
dimostrate stesso che quel bambino stava
fantasticando nel mio caso un bambino
che sognava montagna da scalare con le
piccozze le corde la cinepresa nello
zaino
quasi che la fanciullezza non fosse
altro che un flashback di un film
autobiografico già realizzato
l'entusiasmo l'entusiamo è come il
blizzard che spazza le coste ghiacciate
dello stretto di bering d'inverno
sarà lui a determinare la tua strada una
strada lunga un cammino costante verso
un orizzonte che non è che intravedi
proprio bene ma che sai che esiste
perché ce l'hai già dentro di te come
l'entusiasmo che è un anfratto tra le
rocce dell'insula cerebrale una sorgente
d'acqua purissima certi giorni l'acqua
viene fuori lentamente
altri invece il getto continuo
straripante come un torrente di montagna
in piena tra l'entusiasmo che non a caso
vuol dire pieno di dio a determinare la
tua strada la tua rotta e non si tratta
e non è importante si tratti di una
scorciatoia o di un inutile lunghissima
deviazione avanti sempre avanti seguendo
l'idea primigenia che ti parla con la
freschezza l'ingenuità di un bambino
purtroppo la contingenza della vita
tante volte non ti
ammette di prenderti cura della tua
passione della tua vocazione
in questo la famiglia diventa di grande
importanza perché è spesso all'interno
di una cerca familiare che si impara a
prendersi cura della propria vocazione
non necessariamente la stessa del padre
ma si impara lo stile las forza la
determinazione per raggiungere i propri
sogni per andarsene in giro imposti di
natura estrema bisogna averci fisico e
non è una questione puramente di
allenamento anzi è una questione
abbastanza naturale perché non c'è
esercizio che ti permetta di star bene
senza mal di testa a 78 mi lamento di
quota o in mezzo alle onde dello stretto
di gray di drake o 40 gradi sotto lo
zero o nella giungla tra nugoli di
zanzare portatrici di malaria cerebrale
bisogna essere a posto con se stesso
quando conscio e inconscio lavorano
all'unisono si raggiungo dei livelli
altissimi
non solo in campo alpinistico ma per
fare tutto questo bisogna iniziare da
subito comporre con liturgica attenzione
tutte le tessere di questo enorme
mosaico iniziando al centro come si
trattasse di un mandala di fiori e
polveri colorate magnifico effimero
strepitosa metafora della vita la mia
iniziazione e iniziate cominciata nel
1966 avevo dieci anni e non mi trovavo
aggrappato alla crimine del cavallo come
un bambino mongolo ma in parete legato
con mio padre e un amico è diretto alla
cima del gran zebrù c'era nebbia
andavamo un po piano forse proprio a
causa mia
così mio padre mi disse tu ti fermi qua
e ci aspetta con un serio e molto
incosciente credo anche mi fece un
gradino e io rimasi seduto per più di
un'ora aspettare che mio padre l'altro
andassero in vetta e tornassero non
faceva tanto
non me lo ricordo facesse freddo 3.600
metri le nubi coprivano i canaloni e non
avevo questa sensazione di cadere però
quello retta lì mi ha fatto capire una
cosa che l'alpinismo non era un gioco e
neanche uno sport era qualcosa di più
paghi settimane dopo stava scendendo da
un'altra montagna una volta non c'erano
le previsioni meteo per cui a sabato
domenica si andava se la si prendeva
pace stanno scendendo in mezzo alla
bufera
e a un certo punto ne padre si
preoccupava abbiamo trovato un blocco né
di roccia si sa nascosti dietro a vivere
vicino per guardarmi faccia per vedere
come stavo
stavo da dio tanto che gli dissi per la
cinepresa film ci un po il mio padre mi
disse in montagna quando c'è il maltempo
non ci si perde non si perde tempo
filmare ecco cosa avrei fatto nella vita
andare in montagna a scalare montagne
filmarle anche con la bufera per
superare mio padre per dimostrargli che
aveva fatto bene a mettermi al mondo a
24 anni iniziava il mio personalissimo
torneo di lotta del nolano avevo finito
il mio iter formativo ero l'istruttore
della guida alpina e maestro di sci
diplomato all'istituto superiore di
educazione fisica con una tesi sulla
cinematografia girata sulla parete sud
rail capitan via salate 36 lunghezza di
corda cinque giorni di scalata allora
tra le vie più difficili del mondo
durante la scalata ripresi i miei
compagni con un super 8 ecco la macchina
fotografica tornato poi dalla california
cominciai ad analizzare gli scatti
immobili perfetti della via delle
diapositive con le riprese traballanti
piccoletto e un po sfocate dai super hot
e capii che la fotografia con la sua
solennità con la sua capacità di
assoluta di frizzare il tempo era mezzo
un po troppo complesso per me preferivo
la cinematografia il 24 25 fotogrammi
sono sistema molto più facile per
raccontare
diapositive e super8 fino al mio primo
documentario girato in 16 mm e non in
patagonia in karakorum himalaya ma le
isole seychelles
l'idea di trovare le montagne da
un'altra parte dove nessuno aveva ancora
cercato e mi eccitava così riuscire a
comporre un trittico di scalate e
documentari sulla sull'alpinismo
equatoriale diciamo prima in polini il
prima in alle seychelles
poi in thailandia dove nessuno aveva
ancora scalata alla fine nel posto più
lontano che esiste arcipelago delle
tuamotu polinesi della francese l'isola
fantasma di marcate a qui con il mio
gruppetto di amici inventare questo
sistema per sollevare il camerano in
modo che seguisse lo scalatore
un'esperienza bellissima
il progetto spesso di fifa nel pacifico
il titolo era simpatico era l'idea di
far scalare un sud tirolese e un
cannibale ma mi resi conto perfettamente
che agli alpinisti alla gente che guarda
i cd montagna interessi soltanto un
genere l'epico per il grottesco forse
era un po troppo presto
poche cose sono realmente drammatica
come una montagna che cade nel mare la
differenza tra la verticalità
l'orizzontalità la solidità della pietra
e il mare in continuo movimento
dove c'è veramente la sintesi tra mare e
montagna e la terra di graham penisola
antartica posto pazzesco disabitato dove
poter compiere salite in montagna come
quelle dei prima nieri inglesi alla fine
dell'ottocento su cime vergini giusto
per il piacere storico e geografico di
essere il primo mammifero a metterci
piede è un richiamo forte intenso quello
delle montagne lo stesso che proviene
dal fondo della terra dai sottani
profondi micidiali di 3 400 metri nella
terra dentro le quali calarsi con le
cose
ma non per raccontare imprese
alpinistiche os teleologiche per
raccontare storie di paura a date i
ragazzi oppure andare alla ricerca di
fantomatici animali come le bjorn iss
labirinto i gusti che secondo me
potrebbe ancora vivere negli stinchi di
ben mara la foresta pietrificata del
madagascar o in congo o in papua dove la
gente vive ancora sulle piante per paura
dei nemici dei serpenti e degli spiriti
maligni
ho continuato a filmare in pellicola
fino alla metà degli anni novanta per
viaggio in mongolia ho mescolato il mini
dv con un montaggio anche un po più
serrato con la solennità del 16 mm era
diventato molto più semplice più
elegante più veloce e meno costoso
lavorare in video però mi mancava un po
il momento dell'attesa quando aspetti
che arrivi la luce giusta prima di
tirare la levetta dalla cinepresa è
bellissima cosa l'attesa è come il
profumo che esce dal retrobottega di una
pasticceria e che ti sussurra tra il
periodo facile dal naso guarda che i
cannoncini alla crema sono pronti veloce
qui invece era diventato un po troppo
semplice tutto sommato anche se apprezzo
la semplicità non c'era più il rumore
della cinepresa dalla pellicola che
giravano lo chassis è che ricordava il
sangue che vi che gira nelle vene
soltanto un pallino rosso e una scritta
in fondo al viewfinder rec col video
semplicissimo hai girato una scena vuoi
esserne sicuro nella realizzazione
rewind e traguardi subito con la
cinepresa dove tornare a casa per stare
in negativi a sviluppare quante volte ha
sbagliato ball ex moglie apcom eichler
sempre cineprese francesi mi ha messo in
crisi ma si sa i francesi non è che
siano megan di meccanici
la differenza la conoscente tra paradiso
e inferno
in paradiso il francese fa il cuoco il
tedesco fa il meccanico l'inglese fa il
poliziotto l'italiano fa l'amante e lo
svizzero tiene alla cassa comune ma
l'inferno
il francese fa il meccanico
il tedesco fa il poliziotto l'inglese fa
il cuoco lo svizzero fa l'amante e
l'italiano tiene la cassa comune pal
secam enti essi trequarti sedici noni
per fortuna finalmente siamo arrivati a
uno standard comune per tutta la terra
la hd con mio figlio lucas ho
sperimentato a lungo il 3d la
stereoscopia in montagna e meravigliosa
da un effetto di profondità spettacolare
in un'officina alabastro benso fatto
costruire un hub in splitter
leggerissima in modo di portare due
camere affiancate in cima alla montagna
in 3d abbiamo girato un teaser di un
thriller che ho scritto che adesso è
uscito in fumetto che si chiama the hutt
l'aspetta questa storia 27 anni fa e
ogni inverno immancabilmente da allora
attento di tutti in mente di
trasformarla in film inviare la storia
di tutti di oggi la visione integrata a
360 gradi con suono ambi fonico per ora
i buggles per guardarlo non è che siano
di grande qualità ma è questione di poco
poche cose in tecnologia hanno la stessa
velocità di ricerca dei sensori dei chip
in grado di convertire la luce in
scarica elettrica in carica elettrica
quindi in informazioni digitali ma non è
quasi mai una questione di qualità
dell'immagine
perché ciò che conta veramente e lo
storytelling la capacità di raccontare a
qualcuno qualcosa oggi si possono fare
documentari bellissime con dei semplici
telefonini e qui veniamo la terza prova
del madame quella adatta alla precisione
alla cura in questo periodo sto girando
attorno al lago
a brescia alcuni documentari sta
cercando di documentare gli ultimi
lavori i contadini della panoramica un
tempo porto della città
il pescatore del garda dove i coregoni
non nascono più nel lago ma in un
incubatoio a desenzano oggi filmare è
diventato facilissimo un gesto
quotidiano per quasi tutti i ragazzi che
amano può stare tutto quello che succede
a loro anche le cose più banali su un
social network senza sapere che tutto
quello che va in rete
resta archiviato per sempre
facce di ragazze che si abbracciano in
urss elfi le voci dei nonni che parlano
ancora dialetto vivranno per sempre come
i parigini con la bombetta che
attraversavano in un pomeriggio
qualsiasi la strada tra le carrozze i
cani le donnine con l'ombrello
mentre uno dei fratelli lumière azionava
la manetta dalla sua cinepresa come i
300 alpini della guerra bianca firmati
da luca comerio le loro figure
bianconero traballanti mentre trascinano
un canone pesantissimo fino in cima alla
montagna è successo cento anni fa come
oggi qui in adamello poco distante da
noi li hanno resi immortali frammenti
fotogrammi di una realtà universale per
questo ogni volta che firmiamo con il
nostro smartphone
dovremmo metterci molta più cura e non
la bulimia video che è generata dalla
facilità quasi sfacciata con cui adesso
si può registrare immagini e suoni
perché tutto ciò che va in rete
racconta di noi racconta della nostra
vita e la traccia del nostro passaggio
nella traccia del nostro passaggio sulla
terra per questo meriterebbe molta più
attenzione cura e precisione la stessa
degli artieri della ram
[Applauso]